nicolas vidal directeur de la
publication de putsch médias nicolas
vidal bonsoir merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur fc france alors première
réaction peut être au point d'olivier
ferrand finalement on a entendu en des
termes plutôt positif frémissement
positif par exemple même si le virus
circule activement
quel est votre regard sur cette
communication hebdomadaire du
gouvernement elle est nécessaire à leur
première action observations moi j'ai
trouvé qu'on a voulu dire ça va mieux
mais ça va moins bien
olivier ferrand vous l'avez vu alors moi
j'ai noté la présence comme tout le
monde comme vous et tout le monde de la
raison du docteur chrono fontanier je
les ai vus comme un maître de stage en
offrons d'années parce qu'olivier
ferrand a une nouvelle fois à mon avis
un gros doute ou la capacité sur la
légitimité à dire là à dire la situation
est donc on nous avait finalement une
espèce de cours d'effectuer logis avec
des graphiques des pauvres on se serait
cru dans deux séminaires et je trouve
que sa démarche sa demande finalement
les capacités à vis des vers en a
abandonné et donner les politiques
claires et surtout que les français
croient ce qu'ils racontent aux libéraux
voilà pour la première observation que
j'ai fait on va dire comment pratiquer
pas de mesures restrictives annoncé ce
soir
est ce que ça veut dire que les maires
ont eu gain de cause c'était certains
ont rencontré un leur premier ministre
ce matin
ou alors est-ce que c'est l'état qui se
donne pas un peu de sursis car
l'acceptabilité des français s'étiole
vous avez raison on y vient
effectivement on a vu des fuites de
martine aubry le moudenc aussi à
toulouse martine aubry pro line dance à
toulouse effectivement qui sont réjouis
qu'on leur laisse une espèce de sursis
et puis je voudrais communauté quelque
chose
finalement les restaurateurs avec leur
franc de large à que riche d oser dire
en ligue 1 ne pas parce qu'il ya eu un
manifestement rétropédalage de la part
du gouvernement qui quand même pris une
fronde ayant notant aussi que quand les
blancs ou pas de concertation la
concertation à marseille n'hésitez pas à
l'idée que la concertation c'est à dire
qu'on a imposé à marseille des mesures
extrêmement coercitives et je suis pas
l'idée que le plus apte que
l'orientation au pardon surtout quand
jean castex se veut le premier ministre
des territoires lob de prades
voilà on est pas on n'est pas des plumes
à la concertation de ce côté là
justement pour les restaurateurs est ce
que vous avez senti un deux poids deux
mesures entre marseille contre paris
lyon grenoble et comment vous pourriez
l'expliqué finalement alors je vais me
définir comme un virus par aurélien vous
savez c'est george orwell 284 finalement
on s'en prend à lui de convaincre
compétitivité des bars les restaurants
mais par contre en ce qui concerne brr
les métro les bus et tout ce qui fait
les centres commerciaux aussi le virus
apparemment réussi attaque par donc on
peut comprendre tanga sport à perdre
même en tant que français se poser
légitimement la question de savoir
quelle est la cohérence de ces
dispositifs de ses mesures sanitaires
on a du mal à comprendre pour ceux qui
habitent à paris en convoi les lignes de
métro bondée le matin meilleur banc des
lions vient dire aux restaurateurs que
ça sera même deux heures pour l'instant
est peut-être une fermeture totale des
lieux d'ici finalement le baril passe en
alerte maximale comme d'autres
métropoles
donc on ne comprend absolument rien et
une nouvelle fois ça et quand la
légitimité de la politique du
gouvernement sur cette question là en
tout nouveau en tout cas effectivement
paris qui pourrait passer en zone d'
alerte maximale dès lundi pourquoi lundi
pourquoi pas ce soir là encore un
flottement vous trouvez du gouvernement
bien entendu personne moi ce qui me ce
qui m'effraie danser dans ses
déclarations et ça c'est vrai depuis le
début c'est à dire qu'on fait une
politique de flux tendus
on est à 30 % d'occupation des docks
auvitu la réanimation il à résister
c'est la question que je pose de france
ce soir
combien y avait-il de l'île de man i
mation en mars combien il
de l'hydre animations aujourd'hui au 1er
octobre 2020 c'est à dire que le
gouvernement ne veut pas dépasser le
seuil des 30% mais la réalité
aujourd'hui c'est qu'avec la case dans
l'hôpital public on n'a pas vu des
moyens le seul hôpital a rappelé roux
olivier le grand discours d' emmanuel
macron à mulhouse qui nous a dit la main
sur le coeur je vais faire un grand plan
sur l'hôpital la réalité c'est qu'il ya
pas de plan d'eau potable on aurait
parfois redondantes et lui remet la
réalité aussi c'est qu'il ya aujourd'hui
des urgences qui sont en grève qui sont
remis en grève ils gouvernent finalement
actions de politique du flux tendu donc
préfère finalement mettre en veille avec
une série les restaurateurs les bars
tout série d'activités finalement pour
masquer aussi que l'impéritie du
gouvernement à prendre en main l'utah
public lui donner des moyens pour idées
libérales délit pérenne et on parlera
aussi de bousquet un respirateur curare
et tout ce qu'il fait aussi la
réanimation pour est pas dans les
meilleures conditions pour les patients
que nous sommes et citoyens français que
nous sommes
mais olivier vidal comment vous le
comprenez parce qu'au fond d'un côté on
a des centaines de milliards débloqués
assez rapidement pour pour l'économie de
l'autre effectivement dans la sentiment
que ça traîne pour l'hôpital public et
même bien avant le co lead domicile rt
france on a couvert de nombreuses
manifestations de deux soignants de
médecins qui alerté justement sur l'état
de l'hôpital public comment est ce que
vous comprenez finalement que ça traîne
un petit peu sur ce dossier là parce que
butelle public je vais revenir je vais
refaire la petite musique de l'union
européenne mais aujourd'hui on a une
volonté de ne pas augmenter les visites
publiques d'austérité de paupérisation
de privatisation de tous les services
publics ça passera aussi par l'hôpital
fait pas et présente aux roots et passer
par les barrages et outlook série de
choses adp autres et aujourd'hui on n'a
pas envie de mettre le paquet pour
prendre en contre et une vulgaire
trivial sur l'hôpital public parce que
c'est investir massivement dans les
services publics et l'union européenne
s'y oppose farouchement et s'y oppose
farouchement et notre côté aussi
je précise une dernière chose que j'ai
oublié c'est qu'on n'a pas fermé les
frontières aussi pendant pendant la
crise ducobu de la france était le seul
cap afin de les frontières vont
finalement la cadreuse pital public est
là l'idéologie néolibérale fait qu'on
essaie de maistre sommes absolument
d'austérité et on ne veut pas mettre de
l'argent dans le service public on
privatise à fond voilà aujourd'hui on se
retrouve ces situations est
manifestement ces gens là n'ont pas conc
ne veulent pas investir massivement dit
on nous sort toujours de la
communication gouvernementale en
permanence et ça ne passe plus auprès
des pensées des français et à juste
titre alors ce matin emmanuel macron
s'est lui aussi exprimé sur la situation
sanitaire et économique en france devant
un parterre de chefs d'entreprise
il a dit il a appelé les chefs
d'entreprise à ne pas douter à investir
même si on sait pas trop où on va
comment est ce que vous comprenez ces
déclarations manuel a grandi t il aidé à
des postures du chef de l'état mais
concrètement aujourd'hui qu'on voit on
peut citer plus des stands on peut citer
auchan on peut citer une série dans
queens en train de licencier massivement
face à une mondialisation effrénée et
aujourd'hui quand vous avez vous eu le
maire mise de l'économie je le précise
qui supplie les chefs d'entreprise les
grands groupes à ne pas appliquer la
directive travers des tâches et l'état
la réalité n'a perdu ses pouvoirs
régaliens d'imposer un moment donné sa
souveraineté donc aujourd'hui on est
ouvert aux quatre vents et on est en
concurrence avec le monde entier avec
l'europe ans pour commencer par l'europe
au regard des bridgestone qu'il reprend
là dessus les haies stone va délocaliser
en pologne en hongrie il va fermer son
usine son usine avec une donc
aujourd'hui vous voyez bien que bruno le
maire ne fait que supplier conseiller
sulfuré mais ne peut rien imposer donc
avec s'excuse du pot vide et avec la
mondialisation ça va être une
convergence d'une double crise sociale
populaire qui va être absolument
terrible et on commence à voir les étés
on commence à voir les effets dès
maintenant et ça va être très
sincèrement une fois très inquiet de la
situation économique dans les joues
effectivement le saut kurt populaire
alerté hier peut-être pour conclure
toujours sur la question économique les
secteurs protégés indemnisé à 100%
jusqu'à fin décembre suffisant selon
vous alors très sincèrement je ne
voudrais pas en tant que journaliste je
dispute avec pas mal de restaurateurs
depuis dix jours même depuis très
longtemps mais le but dix jours
particulièrement c'est sans ces gens là
ne voit pas ces prêts arrivés de quoi
passer donc on peut c'est une espèce de
décision on veut dire qu'ils viennent
d'en haut verticale et on ne voit
absolument pas pour ces gens il ne m'a
absolument pas le bien qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui
lee c'est bien joli de prendre des
précautions
là dessus ou des décisions mais on en
haut niveau ainsi que le le restaurateur
le quartier dans toute la france puisse
immédiatement touchent des aides
parce que sinon ces gens sont en train
de monde ils sont en train de mourir
donc vous savez des déclarations il faut
aussi qu'elle se réalise dans les apps
ou les territoires il y avait encore une
espèce de déconnexion d'un décalage
technocratique qui est en train de
mettre le pays à genoux
et toute cette france périphérique il a
fait tourner je le rappelle pendant
merci beaucoup
nicolas vidal d'avoir partagé votre
réflexion je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de publication de putsch
médias